This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
Last weekend I was driving from London to Anglesian Wales
when I saw a road sign written in two languages.
It said, welcome to Wales in English.
And below that, it said,
Kroiso Gumri in Welsh.
Yes, Welsh is spoken by many people in North Wales.
It's the indigenous language.
The language spoken by the people who originally lived in a place,
rather than by others, who moved there from somewhere else.
Welsh is a good example of an indigenous language that has survived.
Some children speak Welsh in school
and the local government has encouraged its spread,
but not all indigenous languages have been so lucky
as we'll be finding out in this programme.
Of course, languages are more than just words.
They carry people's history, culture and identity.
So when an indigenous language disappears,
so too does the culture.
Yes, the dominance of international languages,
including English, has endangered other less spoken languages.
So here's my quiz question, Sam.
Did you know that nearly 7,000 different languages are spoken around the world,
but how many of them are indigenous?
Is it A, 3,000, B, 4,000 or C, 5,000?
Hmm, I'll say B, 4,000 languages.
Okay, Sam, we'll find out the answer at the end of the programme.
One indigenous language speaker is Michko Gabwyd Kwe.
She's from Canada or Turtle Island, as it's called by her tribe.
She grew up speaking English instead of her native language,
Anishi Nabe Mowin, which she only learned later as an adult.
Listen to Michko Gabwyd speaking with BBC World Service programme,
the conversation about how she felt learning
Anishi Nabe Mowin later in life.
When I realised that the sounds that were coming out of my mouth
were the same sounds that had come out of my ancestors' mouth
thousands of years ago, I felt a deep sense of who I was
and what it means to be anishonabic.
And it made me realise that my dream of learning this language
and passing it on to my children was now accessible,
was now reachable, attainable.
And after a couple of months, I was able to understand one full prayer
that was said at a ceremony feast.
And the glee in me and the feeling of joy
of being able to understand something in my own language,
it was the most profound sense of confidence.
Learning to speak the language of her ancestors
gave Michko Gabwyd glee a feeling of happiness, pleasure or excitement.
Although she didn't grow up speaking, Anishi Nabe Mowin,
she now wants to pass it on to her children.
To pass something on means to give it to someone,
usually in your family, who lives on after you die.
Michko Gabwyd's decision to raise her children
speaking Anishina Bimoin turned out to be the right one,
as she explained to BBC World Service Program the conversation.
There's lots of bumps in the road, but it's going very well.
My daughter is turning four and she completely understands the language.
Being put back into daycare, which she's only been there for maybe a month,
has really influenced her English.
So I noticed she's speaking a lot of English.
And so that was a little bit rough for the family,
being an immersion home where we only speak Nishina Bimoin in the home,
for there to be so much English.
And only recently over the last week and a half,
have we really noticed her switch and her shift back into using the language?
Bringing up her children to speak her indigenous language wasn't easy.
And Michko Gabwyd said there were some bumps in the road,
small problems or delays that slowed down or stopped things from developing.
To help her family spoke only Anishina Bimoin at home,
using a technique called immersion.
The process of learning a language or skill by using only that and nothing else.
This meant that Michko Gabwyd's children spoke both English at school
and Anishina Bimoin at home.
She noticed how they changed between languages when speaking,
something known as code switching.
Michko Gabwyd believes this not only helps her children's development,
but also gives them a sense of family history,
as well as preserving her traditional culture.
A culture she hopes they will pass on to their children in turn.
So while indigenous cultures are threatened by big global languages,
there still hope that many will survive into the future.
Which reminds me of your quiz question, Neil.
Was my answer right?
Ah yes, I asked Sam how many of the 7,000 languages spoken around the world are indigenous?
And I thought it was B, 4,000 languages.
Which was the correct answer.
And what's amazing is that although indigenous peoples make up
under 6% of the global population,
they speak more than 4,000 of the world's languages.
Okay, Neil, let's recap the vocabulary from this program on Indigenous Languages.
Languages spoken by the people who originally lived in a place,
rather than others who came later.
Glee is a feeling of happiness or excitement.
If you pass something on, you give it to someone,
usually in your family, who lives on after you.
A bump in the road is a small problem or delay that slows things down.
Immersion is a process of learning something,
like a language or a skill,
by using only that and nothing else.
And finally, code switching is the ability to change between two or more languages when speaking.
That's all for Mass. Bye for now.
Bye-bye.